thanks you guys for coming my name is
Tony and this talk is going to be about
making big data smaller and to be honest
I'm phone I'm never so I'm not sure
about your Christmas I'm nervous l and
if you see me drinking water system not
nervous tic and every time I do that
hopefully I get a little more calmer if
you guys have any questions feel free to
ask so a little bit about me I'm from
San Francisco and in San Francisco I
organized the San Francisco Bay Area
machine learning meetup group so if you
guys are ever in San Francisco and like
the sword topic feel free to hit me up
feel free to join a meetup group and we
do events once or twice every month I'm
also working on a site called SF data
jumps and the main premise behind that
is if you're looking for a job in San
Francisco no I want this would be like
the premier source rate you know there's
countless people who come to me ask me
hey Tony what what startups are in which
what's that what startups in the Bay
Area or do machine learning and which
one which would you recommend so I got
tired of people asked me out so I just
created this list so far this list of
machine learning jobs in san francisco
or machine learning companies in san
francisco and that's that right now and
it's going to be i'm hoping to turn into
a job board i'm hoping i turn into more
than that soon s1 background I come from
a computer science background I have a
master's in computer science with
focused on machine learning computer
vision and for the past four years I've
been a data engineer at tech company and
more recently of start doing consulting
work so this talks about big data but
you know what what is data mean well a
lot of people can think of data as the
raw data but for this talk we're going
to get the data as the data that's been
cleaned spin transforms this has its
features extracted so essentially we're
going to look at data that has this sort
of matrix form a you see down here where
there's m observations and there's
capital deep features so basically our
data is the huge as matrix so you know
what is big data actually I'm not too
sure myself so I looked at went on
wikipedia and looked it up and wikipedia
says big data is an all encompassing
term for any collection of data sets so
large so complex that becomes
ultipro system using traditional
processing applications so for me what
does that mean to us what does that mean
to me to me that means he have so much
data that gives you out of memories in
Python there's so much so much data that
you run out disk space yeah so much data
that you get your s3 bill and you're
just crying so much data that you're
willing to set up spark you one step
dupe you roll this up your own cluster
and I'm not sure how many you guys have
done it that's gay pnas so if you have
big data and you really do that it means
you're willing to do on so one question
comes to mind is can we make big data
smaller and if so know where the
benefits of having smaller data so just
off the bat best but the benefits of
having smaller data is you know reducing
our storage costs your s3 bill is gonna
be a little lower another benefit is no
we're going to use less computational
competetive time to process our data
because the data smaller and hopefully
will run we won't run into any more out
of memory errors and you know what are
some ideas for making dig a smaller one
idea is maybe we just reduce the number
of observations one one way is maybe
just keep the observation star
importance whatever that means whatever
important under ideas maybe we don't
want redundant observation system
whatever we done it means maybe we just
remove redundant duplicate data our idea
is it's kind of crazy but this Ramli
sample of the observations maybe we'll
have some really dense day to begin with
and maybe just randomly sample from it
and we'll get something that in my
opinion represents today pretty well but
you know what focuses of this talk isn't
about reducing the number of
observations for this talk I want to
focus more on reducing the number of
features which i think is a little more
interesting at least in my opinion so
we're some ways to reduce the number of
features one way is just to figure out
which pitch are not useful to rush it up
another way it's maybe taking features
and combine them to make them more
useful and maybe we should do something
clever I'm not sure what that that means
maybe this talk will answer that
and I know before we start I want to
give you guys a real life example of how
i use feature reduction or future
reduction in my life so about a year ago
I just started picking up boxing and in
the boxing class you know after first
month I learned enough to get into the
ring spar got my ass whooping that's
fine and what I've noticed was that when
someone's punched me you know it's good
idea unboxing that when someone punch do
you know when win a blocker when it back
up right so you keep key thing that I
want to predict this when is this guy
going to punch me so what I did first
when I was a newbie was I would you know
look at his head I was looking look at
his arms look at his shoulders look at
his foot and when he comes in especially
with it said I'll knows everything I was
react to that and I'm observing
long-dead point sir and as I progress
what I've noticed is no it's a bad idea
to look at the guy's head because can we
look at how you guys you just punch you
down low right so the head is not a
useful information it's not a useful
feature no ideas the arms know these
guys could be faking your own you never
know when it's gonna come in so in my
opinion when you see I'm like launched
in especially with newer folks
especially when especially near folks
when you see them launch in with
especially with the hips it's like
that's a good sign this guy's committing
to a punch so just type of razors with
your guard so you know that that's
example of future reduction in your life
I think all right so what about the sock
again we're going to be focused on
reducing the number of features so we
start off with this data is ms
herbaceous by Big D features his big
matrix and we reduce the number of
features by doing so magic and we're
gonna get this smaller matrix where it's
same number of observations but the
features a lot smaller and when we do
this we want to preserve the distances
between the observations so let's say we
have two random points in the original
matrix the two points in the reduced
matrix should have sort of similar
distance and why is this important well
what are some algorithms guys use anyone
like a nearest neighbors I like I love
it it does well right let's say we take
some observation in the let's say we do
k-nearest neighbors for this first
initial matrix for some observation if
you do the same key nearest neighbors in
the reduced matrix very calm up be the
same right what are the nearest
neighbors are so that's why preserving
the distance matters okay so here's a
question for you guys I say we have this
plateau these four observations and 2d
how can we make these observations go
from 2d to 1d so each point sitrep
seeing as an X wide number we want to
represent just one over any ideas no I
have one I do well before I get to that
these little doubt lines are just the
distances between the points I didn't
draw them what I left out the one from
the very far and Institute's making a
little work there but this again it's
just a lot of the observation said that
the dotted lines are just the distance
between them and so the question is how
do we represent these points into décor
diab servations in 2d as just this is
one number or sorry how do you represent
these 2d observations as 1d so one way
we could go about it is while we just
get rid of the Y information why don't
we when we get where the y axis why we
just project down into the excess while
we collapse all the points down to the x
axis right and so that's called
projecting the observations to the x
axis and i color-coded the distances
here and you see what the distances are
when do you project it down so these
points this point comes here this point
goes down here so support so these two
points come down to two this line and
their distance is this which is sort of
similar to this red line up here right I
think that does pretty well so no does
okay on the x axis what about the y axis
what does that look like so we're
projecting onto y axis and you'll see
that it doesn't do that well you know
the distances aren't really protected
aren't really preserved you see this
orange line here comes really tiny right
here
so no so far I feel that we're getting
good results by projecting it down to
the x-axis but you know what if that's
just an artifact of the data being like
spread horizontally and you know what if
would this technique of just projecting
it down to the x-axis and y-axis still
work the data was rotated a little bit
so let's rotate the data maybe by 45
degrees or so so let's not look like
that and while we just do the same thing
we did before let me take points and
these points and projected down to the
x-axis so now these two points get this
for a distance this blue point these two
points here have this stored distance
and so on so forth and you know the
x-axis doesn't look too bad lip doesn't
look as good as before but the y-axis
now sorts look a little better feel free
to stop maybe I have any questions so
the question then becomes you know
projecting down to x-axis and y-axis
that's fine now but is there a better
coordinate system that we can project
down to we rotated it up maybe there's a
way to be rotated axis well so that we
can reject it down onto it so while we
did that well while we just find
something while we I'm looking at the
data and you know a priority that we
kind of projected it 45 degrees so one
we have a coordinate system is also
rotate about 45 degrees so here's the
new coordinate system and let stupid
this the this one dimension the one
direction of the queerness system this
is an hour what this like the new
coordinate systems X like their y so we
take these points and project it down to
these new coordinates these new
coordinates or these this new coordinate
system will get this we're here just for
here here so this projecting down to the
X and this project you down to the new
why that makes sense yes yeah and so we
can see that this is a lot better than
what we had here agree and so the real
question is you know how do we go about
doing this and how does it relate to
dimensionality reduction well here's
here's the thing you have this new
coordinate system here and we just want
to represent
and hey these points that's whenever you
strut drop water drop water access you
don't care about that make sense no yeah
ok
so we talked about lob lob spread and
you know what's the formal definition
definition of spread here for this top
spread is all considered as the variance
so once you have their points projected
onto onto whatever direction will take
the variance of that and they'll be or
spread and we want to find the
projections that has the largest
sperience for the largest spread and and
so the question becomes how to determine
the observations in the new coordinate
system this might ask if some of you
guys are confused this might help answer
for yes so a 68 point p so in the
original X original XY axis t is some
amount this way and some amount dismay
right here one degree so what is it now
expects you this new axis this is well
at some point here up some Direction
here abstraction here today we want to
know the reason why we want to know what
it is in this new axis so that we can
just know what it is with the values
here what the value is here when we
project it down to two these axes so to
figure that out i just read out some
linear algebra here i go over real quick
you guys want so with this this
direction this coordinate this
represented some vector he's multiply it
by these riginal coordinates in in the
XY axis original x axis and you'll get
you'll get the disk component you do the
same for this vector and you get the
same part so you you'll get this point
of just you pee in the news new
coordinate system so so the main idea is
you have the new coordinate system how
do you represent the point in the
Newport in a system and that's important
because once you throw away different
court different coordinates like how we
did before where we dropped the X or
drop to why it becomes a lower
dimensional representation that's all it
is so just reading the observation that
you're finding the coordinates of snaps
aligned with the spread gives us no good
cornices four dimensional reduction and
directions parallel to
where the data maximizes the hair
pointlessness so just just the
reiteration rehashing of what we said
earlier so question is how do we
actually find us Alliant coordinate
system is there a tool developed for
this well there's it's called pca anyone
heard that yep pc so pci stands for
principal component analysis and
basically all it is is giving us at
observations find an aligned coordinate
system like what we did for where the
first direction or the first first basis
of our first direction of the new
coordinate system contains the most
spread in the fall about a second well
about the third so on and so forth where
each each coordinate or each direction
has to be orthogonal to each other or
orthogonal to each other and to actually
compute this it's going to require of M
cubed what that means is for we have
observations it's going to take at least
m cube time m cube times to solve it and
the reason why is your net is because
it's doing like singular value
decomposition or some for a comparison
or not so no that's all fine dandy and
probably some of you guys don't really
care about what the math is or how it
really works and you guess one just have
the tool set to use it right so here's
how you actually use it as a real simple
it's couple lines so let's say let's say
you have an X which is a matrix of M by
M observation Spidey features you import
this s can learn the decomposition or
import PCA from this modular here and
you Stan she ate accentuate this piece a
class with the number of components that
you want to reduce your original
dementia tooth so you have a big deal
over there and now you want to make it
too small G so now you have this PC a
variable now you fit your data to not
know you fit now you find now you fit
the data to now use pca to fit the new
coordinate system to the data and now
you take the data and you transform it
into the lower dimension and at the end
you'll give you a em by small g
matrix that's all it is so you guys go
home right now and just play with that
you'll see the data transferring to a
lower dimension and still has a point
this is preserved again just to just to
make the point real clear we what we
just did was we have this matrix small
and by Big D and we transferred it to em
by small G which is a lot smaller than
before and we preserve the distance
between observations and here's what it
looks like here's an example data in 3d
here's some data we fit a 3d coordinate
system to it that this long axis here
maximizes the spread sec one maximize
this second spread and so on so forth
and you want to do dimensionality
reduction alright so we know that this
third Direction here doesn't give us
much spirit so we remove that so now we
just have this v1 or now we just have
this two-dimensional sort of plane and
we graph that out looks like that so
let's mess with you know I'm a vision
guy let's mess with some real real data
so what if our data is images how do we
represent an image as an observation
right how do you represent image as a
point in graph right so here's this
here's here's this image of a guy's face
it's basically a 100 by 100 matrix where
each element is sort of a pixel
intensity so how do you represent a
matrix as a point right well one thing
that we can do is we take each row other
of the image and just string you along
together so we just basically vectorize
it up you plan it out and we get this
100 by 100 dimensional vector which is
10k alright and so one question is given
this came to go back the other way
around given this 10 to 10 dimensional
vector can we go back to this image this
image matrix we can't be just chop it up
by hundreds and just restock it right
and so here's the note here's another
guy with that we vector eyes or ears
when I got that represent as the
observation or
as a 10 K vector and we supplied it into
this this graph so here you notice that
there's there's 100 or there's a 10,000
features and so there's 10,000
components here so we plot some work
faces and now if you run PCA we're going
to find the new coordinate system where
it has 10,000 directions Ted ten
thousand coordinates right so that's
final now what does that mean for us
right well remember how I said that a
vector can be represented as a matrix
image matrix here's an idea while we
take these coordinates and when we
represent them so each cornet can be
represent it has no just just a vector
right and while we take the vector e of
the coordinates and represent it as an
image when we stack into image and
visualize it well if you do that we'll
see that the very first the very first
coordinate has this for face or hear the
second one has his face and so on so
forth and this the bear last one and and
we'll see that well this more the of the
coordinates being visualized so we'll
see that a face can't be representing
the new and the new coordinate system as
basically waits for different
coordinates so here's our original image
and there's 10,000 coordinates for the
for the coordinate system and we have a
way for you to one them so you know what
if we threw away alone well what would
happen if we just kept 20 and represent
represent the image that way well we'll
get something like this this looks looks
sort of similar but it's slow fuzzy only
increase it to say 90 increases to 90 we
actually get something that's fairly
similar to the original image I can't
tell the difference and so what we have
here is we're able to do compression
using PCA and just as a quick note on on
on what we're doing here the original
for one image we originally had had a
represented with thousand ten thousand
values for the compress for compressing
the image we only need to have the 90
weights to actually get get it to
something that we can recognize and in
addition to its ninety weights we need
to have those 90 components of that
coordinate system that we were talking
about so for one image it doesn't make
sense to do this compression let's say
for a 200 image so in the original if
you want to represent original 200
images we would need 200 of these 10,000
vectors right for a compression we just
have this the Act the 90 axis or the 90
coordinates and the 90 the 90 waits for
for each each one of those set makes
sense all right so it makes sense to use
this hanging when we have 90 90 or more
images to compress so keep in mind that
the runtimes n cubed for PCA and we need
to keep round data that the matrix for
the we need to keep around the new
coordinate system to project down to
which is d by d and requires and the
caveat here is your MPC actually read in
all the data points to actually compute
the new cornice computer spread and know
it works really well for data that's
short linear but what if the data was
curved like this down here would piece a
work for it probably not not not too
well so here's a crazy idea well we just
create a d by small D by Big D matrix P
where the elements are just roundly
drawn and so now we have this matrix
assistant random as matrix and let's say
you have some point in big d space x it
and now you skip a representation in the
smaller g right how many people think
that works no maybe
when I first heard about saying no way
works so let's see let's try to get the
intuition for it so in PCA we were
talking about like finding these new
coordinate system that aligned with the
day right so what went what r and
projection says is I don't care what the
coordinate system it's just give me some
random-ass coordinate system so I'll
find them some random random vector here
then I'll put it here and whatever and
you can see that it kind of works if
what are you coordinate is isn't like
tube up to off and there's not a lot of
positions where it could be really off
all right so if i had my my projected
down here it will look too bad and maybe
I ran lead role under one it look like
that it's not too bad so that's sort of
the intuition behind it and you know
intuitions fine but you want
mathematical guarantees right oh and
just keep your actions here so the
question is what is the safe value for D
well here's a there's a really easy
answer that excuses uses them use this
function here in side the side
q-learning ran a projection library so
you specify how many observation you
have and how much air your voluntary and
we'll get to that in a second and it'll
give you the number dimensions that you
need to in order to safely project down
the data to random so space so here's a
guarantee so given two points this
original distance will be 1 minus
epsilon off from its projected distance
or is bounded by it the projected
distance is bounded by the original
distance with the plus/minus factor of 1
minus epsilon and and your guarantee
that if you have a dimension of greater
equal to 4 log M blah blah blah and you
don't need to worry about that all you
need to do is plug in your your
variables here and i'll tell you how
much you need to put in how many
dimensions you safely predict project
down to and you know the practical usage
of this is you know there's a high
probability that projection will be good
but there still a chance that it won't
be good and in that case one way to
guarantee one way to safeguard against
ad has created a bunch of mana
projections and as you're going through
your data just keep note of which ones
are doing well which ones aren't
installing the ones that aren't doing
well and so just a recap of what we
talked about so PCA four tries to find a
line coordinate system where the
coordinates sort of maximizes the spread
it runs in time and requires all points
to be written we just kind of sucks and
then it acquires M by D space requires
requires a acquires the projection
matrix as well for Randy projection it
finds random random coordinate system
and it requires the D by D matrix to do
the projection and is guaranteed to work
with high probability and all right
that's it a questions it's a lot
smoother when I didn't practice but well
thank you guys for listen it to me
hopefully that was arantania hopefully
that was useful feel free to PM you guys
have any questions or if you our on san
francisco need someone here yeah
absolutely yeah and there's more
resources references you guys mom play
around with it well thank yes